welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in
in major boxing news heavyweight tyson
fury posts the video to social media
announcing he is coming out of
retirement and who will train him for
his next bout tyson why have you decided
to come back to boxing and why have you
chosen isaac glow to be your coach well
andy i've decided to come back to boxing
because i can be the first heavyweight
champion in history to have two
trilogies one with deontay wilder and
the second one with derek azara i always
said i'd play you guy which has already
ended my career and here we are breaking
all records again set presidents and
what i've chosen is it lowers me trainer
is because when i was with peter isaac
was there when i was with them as it's
always been there and when i was with
sugar hill isaac's always been there
he's always giving information he knows
me better than anybody on the planet um
we're a great team we've always been
together and we're going to finish this
out together um we've always worked very
well together and here we are about to
take on a massive massive massive event
isaac yeah i'm looking forward to it
it's a new challenge for me and uh i
think this i've been with your all your
career and i think i can put something
new together so looking forward to it
and it's a tough task for someone to
look forward to to go forward
fury announced his retirement after he
defeated dylan white in april but now
has his eyes set on a trilogy with derek
chizora fury's previous fights against
chizura both ended with victories a
unanimous decision in 2011 and by rtd in
2014. staying in the boxing world oscar
de la hoya gave an update on a potential
fight between ryan garcia and jervante
tank davis over the weekend hopefully
boxing fans didn't get their hopes too
high for the potential super fight
because according to de la hoya the
fight is all but dead de la hoya told es
news that he is looking elsewhere for
garcia's next opponent last thing any
update on ryan and tank uh negotiations
zero whatsoever but there are talks
hey we're trying to get a hold of
tanks we don't know who to talk to
nobody picks up their phone
nobody calls back
i feel they're playing games so i'm
moving on
and i'm going to teal females fight next
week there you have ashley
de la hoya will be at tiofimo lopez's
next fight and it seems like a fight
between lopez and garcia could
materialize when asked by max kellerman
on a recent episode of max unboxing if a
fight with ryan garcia interested him
lopez didn't hold back
honestly to be real i'm willing to take
on anyone i've always been that way it's
the takeover nothing really changes from
this point forward former ufc light
heavyweight champion yan wakovic made
his case to dana white on twitter that
he deserves to challenge yurya prohaska
for the light heavyweight title wakovic
opened up with a list of facts about
himself in the tweet facts as a first
male fighter in poland i became the ufc
champion because of my work my name
garners respect never shied away from
any challenge i went to the ufc to
create great moments for the fans i'm
not done yet he followed that tweet with
another directly asking dana for the
title shot at dana white no [ __ ] no
politics no nonsense give me prohaska
and i'll give you the biggest mma fight
in europe's history unlike him i always
keep my word tony ferguson has a new
fight team according to a post on social
media ferguson will now be fighting
under the jackson wink mma name out of
new mexico ferguson has lost his last
four fights and is looking for change to
get him back on track jackson wink mma
has an impressive list of alumni
including holly holm and jon jones will
ferguson's first opponent fighting out
of his new gym be dan hooker hooker has
called out ferguson multiple times over
the past couple of weeks and did so
again days ago in a tweet madison square
garden ufc 281 let's get it done tony
ferguson sean shelby dana white fighting
at ufc 281 would put hooker on the same
card as fellow new zealander and
middleweight champion israel adesanya
hooker spoke more about the potential
fight with ferguson at msg on the
all-star youtube channel stylebender
messaged me and said bro get that tony
fight on the msg card november 12th i've
been trying to fight since august they
couldn't get me anyone in august i've
been trying to fight in october still
can't get anything across the line
november he's got absolutely no excuses
i don't know who else he thinks he's
gonna fight what else is there for tony
i think it's the biggest fight that he
can get himself and msg works you can't
get ready in 12 weeks or 13 weeks like
just your tire then if you can't get
your arse out of bed for 12 weeks then
just piss off and retire that's how i
feel about it style bender wants it i
want it what do you say tony
mma judge seth fuller received harsh
criticism after the events of ufc 277
commentators joe rogan and daniel
cormier were extremely hard towards
fuller after scoring differently than
his colleagues during the hom the abdel
wahab dauntail may's preliminary
heavyweight bout after the scores were
read daniel cormier said to rogan i mean
come on somebody gave dawntail the third
round joe to which rogan responded that
guy needs a talking to we need to check
and see what he bet on fuller feeling
that he took to his personal youtube
account to defend himself after
re-watching the fight fuller stood by
his original score and expressed that he
believed in the third round maze's
striking did more damage despite having
less volume fuller then went on to
explain how in the moment he decided to
do what he felt was right rather than
take the easy way out and i thought
about it i was looking at that paper
like man i can play it safe because
abdul wahab was on top for three minutes
plus
and he landed a lot of those little p
patch sponge so nobody would fault me
but that's not what i'm there for i take
my job very seriously
both of these fighters put their lives
on the line their health on the line and
their money on the line it's not my
fault that the fact that my score can
affect one of their uh purses i don't
think that's right i think that's a
terrible idea but i take it seriously
and i didn't just willy-nilly give out
that score
i decided
i felt maze from everything that i saw
had outscored in damage after wahab in
that round and so i wrote it down
and it's unfair to me not only to be
criticized from it let me show you the
text i got directly after this
this is the text i got from a complete
stranger
who apparently looked my number up on
the internet
fighters having side hustles to earn
some extra cash is nothing new but this
next story even perplexed us over here
at thick boy fight news hannah goldie is
selling the underwear she wore in her
loss to meatball molly mccann at ufc
london goldie posted the auction
announcement on her facebook page i'm
auctioning off the ufc panties i wore to
weigh ins dm me with your bids well
hannah whatever works for you you have
our support over here at thick boy fight
news looking for more original mma
content check out the rest of thick boy
youtube exclusive interviews opinion and
fight analysis is available weekly on
the shob show food truck diaries and
fight night flashbacks subscribe so you
don't miss any of the action
[Music]
you